le tourisme en ile de france reprend des
couleurs après deux années compliquées
marquée par la crise sanitaire cet été
12,6 millions de touristes ont visité la
région est la capitale ces 133 % de plus
par rapport à l'année dernière cet été
cette reprise s'est confirmée et on
s'attend à l'automne à ce que ça encore
plus fort alors c'est un paradoxe mais
l'inflation développe aujourd'hui un
vrai tourisme de proximité en ile de
france où des franciliens vont passer
une nuit à l'hôtel en ile de france vont
découvrir les sites près chez eux et
s'aperçoivent qu'ils auraient une région
magnifique qu'ils connaissent mal c'est
donc dû proche tourisme qui se développe
si 60% des visiteurs sont français les
américains représentent la première
clientèle étrangère
puis viennent les touristes des pays
frontaliers avec en tête les
britanniques les allemands les espagnols
les belges et les néerlandais et puis
nous sommes portés aussi dans cette
dynamique par la hausse du dollar par
rapport à l'euro qui fait que nous avons
une
dynamique extrêmement forte de tourisme
américain de touristes de la zone dollar
que nous allons évidemment encouragé et
nous avons aussi beaucoup d'européens
qui sont venus parce que effectivement
ils préfèrent voyager moins loin
aujourd'hui et c'est aussi un tourisme
plus écologique dans les yvelines les
sites culturels ne font pas grise mine
bien sûr le fameux château de versailles
arrive en pole position cet été et la
doubler ses entrées par rapport à 2021
puis tout de suite après on retrouve le
zoo safari de thoiry se suivent ensuite
la ferme de gally france miniature à
elancourt ou encore le château de
breteuil les touristes cherchent
également de plus en plus le contact
avec la nature puisque la bergerie
nationale et la forêt de rambouillet
reste des sites très fréquentés
alors même si les chiffres de cette
année n'ont rien à voir avec ceux de
2010 neuf années juste avant la crise du
coc vide il reste tout de même
encourageant